i'm the economics editor
of bbc's news night i'm very very
pleased to be here
now before we begin this debate i'm
going to ask the owners to submit
their pre-debate vote because we want to
get a sense
of what your opinions are before we
start so
please vote now for or against the
motion
abolish billionaires via the poll which
is going to be coming up on your screen
and if you're unsure uh vote undecided
um so billionaires what a fantastically
timely topic for a debate the first
thing to say is that there are a lot
more of them than there were
last year forbes is forbes magazine's
annual
list of billionaires puts the total
number worldwide at 2755.
that's 660 more than last year
and it also estimates their collective
wealth now at around 13
trillion dollars that's up from eight
trillion dollars a year earlier there
are so many billionaires that were even
sending them into space to make room
here on earth
jeff bezos as you know went up yesterday
briefly uh
and that's followed richard branson's
trip nine days earlier
so very entertaining no doubt but is it
edifying
is it perhaps a waste of resources on
billionaire vanity projects
and that leads to a bigger question does
the existence
of any billionaire as a billionaire of
course lead let alone
2 000 of them represent as some have
argued an economic policy
failure is it a sign of economic
dysfunction
namely a lack of competition in markets
that
any single individual can get that rich
does it signify economies becoming
increasingly saturated
with economic rent extracting behavior
meaning people
who take wealth from others rather than
creating it for the community
uh and does the inequality so vividly
symbolized by the
billionaire class perhaps serve to
stifle wider economic growth
or on the other hand is the billionaire
boom a reflection of the
opposite does it reflect the increasing
innovation and dynamism
in our economy does the proliferation of
billionaires
represent the brilliance of modern
entrepreneurs
that they're able to build such
leviathans like amazon google
and microsoft and all the rest does it
reflect the risk taking and drive of
people like elon musk
do the riches of these individuals serve
to inspire
and incentivize others to do similarly
brilliant things
should we leave them alone and indeed
wish them happy travels to the stars or
wherever else they want to go
that's the theme of tonight's debate and
here's how it's going to work with the
moment our two speakers are going to
make their
opening statements then i'll be taking
your questions and encouraging some
debate between the speakers
and at 6 50 pm uh the speakers will end
the debate with
uh short closing statements and then i'm
going to invite you all to make your
final vote which i will announce just
before 7pm
as connor mentioned tweet to us or tweet
about the event using the hashtag
iq2 and you can ask a question by
clicking on the ask
question button under the video screen
and don't forget to press
send so but let's get the um
pre-vote results and for the motion that
we should abolish
billionaires uh it is 56
for so that wins against the emotion
that we should abolish billionaires
11 so that's losing ryan
um undecided 33 so there are
votes to uh votes to play for here
so uh now let's get
going um our speaker for the motion
uh i'm very pleased to announce is
lindsay mcgoy she is professor of
sociology and director of the center for
economic sociology
and innovation at the university of
essex she's the author of two books
no such thing as a free gift the gates
foundation and the power of philanthropy
and most recently the unknown is how
strategic
ignorance rules the world she's written
for the new york times and the guardian
on why billionaires are
harmful for society so lindsay
your six minutes take it away thank you
alright done bit
my sister now with whitey
on the moon her face
and arms began to swell
and whities on the moon
i can't pay no doctor bill
but whitey on the moon ten years from
now
i'll be paying still while whities
on the moon when the great
american poet and musician gil scott
herron
wrote those words in 1970
50 years ago now inequality in the
united states was bad
but it was not nearly as bad as it is
today
the us and other countries such as the
uk
had experienced unprecedented narrowing
of wealth gaps over the mid 20th century
how through policies
that are the same ones as the ones
called for
by the motion today through abolishing
the entitlements that wealthy
millionaires had
until citizens and their governments
said
we will no longer be servile to wealth
plutocrats and
i suspect that from my opponent
you might hear a similar phrase
abolish wealth but with a different
emphasis the idea of abolition might be
condemned as an act of violence it will
be seen like an
unfair overstretch of government the
very notion
seems like an attack on billionaire
freedom
to make money however they want
regardless of the cost to others
to gift it however they want to bequeath
it however they want
to use their power to reinforce
the power of their heirs until you get
to the stage where forty percent
of all wealth in a nation like the
united states
is inherited wealth just as it is today
a nation where much like in the uk
poverty is rising and life expectancy
is declining in many regions
a nation where a billionaire like jeff
bezos
the richest man in the world can pay
zero
federal income tax and not only does he
rarely pay any tax but in 2011 his tax
burden
was so low that he was eligible for a
four thousand dollar
child tax credit and he took it
of course he took it just like he is
taking from the workers
his workers their right to organize for
better livelihoods
just like he took tax dollars to boost
himself into space
good thing he did claim that child
credit when you think about it though
because
surely he needed it for say food
fuel to get to space because certainly
it wasn't his own ingenuity or know-how
getting him there the technology was
already funded
by democratic governments the same
governments
that my opponent and his friends at the
cato institute think are so
useless and you know what lately they're
right
lately governments have been useless at
the key criterion the baseline
stipulation
that enlightenment thinkers like adam
smith saw as the fundamental duty of a
civilized
and a accountable government the ability
to make the rich pay
their fair share smith makes this point
in wealth of nations where he sharply
criticizes tax systems in earlier fetal
times because as he saw it
they let the rich get away with gross
abuses of power
back then he writes to quote
the sovereign was obliged to contempt
himself with taxing those
who were too weak to refuse taxation
like the rich did
only a barbaric pre-civilized society
he pointed out places the biggest
proportionate burden
on a society's weakest groups while
allowing the rich
to thumb their noses at governments
which is why it's kind of funny when
people from the cato institute
uphold smith to talk about say market
freedom
for smith true freedom meant an end to
the barbaric privileges
and gross impunity of the excessively
rich and how
do you end those privileges simple
you abolish them you abolish billionaire
power
which is what this motion calls for just
like it was once necessary to reign in
the absolute power
of feudal monarchs and overlords
to abolish their control over the people
we must abolish the power of economic
overlords today continued civilization
this is an existential threat
continued civilization and enlightenment
depend on it
thank you
excellent thank you very much lindsay um
that was slightly under time actually
i'm pleased to say
i've seen any remaining right
but let's go straight to you ryan
oh sorry what's up my apologies let me
introduce you first of course
our speaker against the motion is ryan
bourne
the r evan shaft chair for the public
understanding of economics
at the cato institute he's a regular
public commentator on the economy
and author of an excellent book
economics in one virus an introduction
to economic reasoning through covet 19
which was recently named of financial
times summer read for 2021
so now ryan over to you for your six
minutes
well take two uh thank you so much to
ben and to intelligence square for the
opportunity to debate this motion
abolish billionaires i mean
you've got to admire the candidness of
that title relative to the sorts of
technocratic things i usually debate
and i really do understand the instinct
here because i used to agree
with a professor you see jeff bezos is
massive new mansion here in dc or
richard branson and him firing
themselves into space
then you read about poverty and misery
and homeless people worldwide and i
think it's really seductively easy
to make that intellectual leap that the
poverty of the poor must in some way
be a consequence of the wealth of the
rich or at the very least
that we of course in the form of
government usually could simply take
from the wealthy
and spend that money better and it's
true
if you look at any list of global
billionaires some did make their
fortunes from
the sorts of unjust cronyism that adam
smith railed against
whether it's carlos slim and the mexican
telecoms fortune the russian oligarchs
or even elon musk getting states to
compete to offer tesla special tax
breaks
that's sort of crony capitalism
governments granting privileges like
restrictive intellectual property or
or even subsidies that does push some
people's wealth up
and make some people billionaires that
sort of deck tilting
by government makes us poorer it diverts
resources to unproductive ventures it
encourages lobbying
and i oppose it in all its forms and i
spend much of my time at cato arguing
against it
but the truth is the majority of
billionaires in the us and uk today
didn't get wealthy from government
favors most in fact got extremely rich
by providing the ideas
leadership or capital for products that
we as customers
vote with our wallets to buy because we
value them
uh whatsapp founders brian acton and
jason comb
founded a company in a really globally
competitive instant messaging industry
they grew the business it's now two and
a half billion people in over 180
countries the whatsapp app
generates five to ten billion dollars a
year in annual revenue so when those
founders
sold up to facebook they were of course
rewarded with a cool
combined 15 billion dollars for their
innovation
they didn't rent seek their apparent
crime deserving of abolition
was just to create a trusted product
that slashed the cost dramatically for
millions of people around the world
to stay in contact with their loved ones
and as economist william nordhaus has
said of entrepreneurs who deliver
similar
transformative innovation their riches
might look huge
in absolute terms but that's a mere
slither of the huge consumer value they
created
so why should their wealth be now
plundered and treated as if they're the
same as carlos slim
or a russian oligarch how can we talk
about billionaires
as if they're a common class of people
ignoring how those individuals made
their money
and if you think i'm cherry-picking an
example on the source of billionaire
wealth
the wealthiest 20 people in the world
right now
includes those associated with founding
amazon google microsoft walmart facebook
zara and nike in britain it's dyson
ineos home bargains the vast majority of
billionaires wealth remains in
productive business assets
just two percent is in personal property
like houses
and yachts so what would happen if we
abolish billionaires
well clearly one effect would be we
disincentivize the innovation that got
people like this rich in the first place
now nobody says that wealth is the only
motivator for entrepreneurs
and i can't get in their heads but the
desire to have billions in funds
whether it's to keep score to reinvest
to provide for your heirs
or even to play global savior clearly
does matter to some business people
and as the economist charles jones has
pointed out we'd only need that sort of
wealth conversation or very high taxes
to deter very few
major innovations by reducing that uh
payoff
to be really socially destructive and
given this wealth is in productive
business assets
what would tax in it or taking it away
do
force them to sell their companies
encourage them to give wealth away to
political interest groups with actual
power
incentivize blowing it on consumption
like space races that people apparently
dislike
and for what benefit when we get the
revenue more money for boris johnson to
spend on royal yachts or dodgy bridges
in the north
for context confiscating jeff bezel's
entire wealth
would fund the u.s federal government
for just 11 days
who do you even think would use those
billions to enrich your lives more
through reinvestment
or philanthropy business people like
jeff bezos
or bill gates or politicians like boris
johnson
and donald trump to ask the question i
think is to answer it
now at this stage somebody usually says
put all that aside but nobody deserves a
billion dollars
so let's consider a thought experiment
let's imagine a world where everyone was
equally productive earned the same
income paid the same taxes that was
perfect equality
suddenly one person in that society
comes up with a brilliant idea
for an appliance that could transform
your life by say
cleaning your house automatically with
no human input whenever it got dirty
so brilliant a product in fact that
everybody in the world wants one and
buys one
as a result of that innovation the owner
the founder of that company would
probably end up a comfortable
billionaire
what message would we send by then
confiscating this wealth
and redistributing it to maintain
equality
i contend that most billionaires do make
their money through this sort of honest
value creation
that disincentivizing that process is a
bad idea
and that actually letting markets not
governments and not the professor
allocate wealth has coincided with the
huge enrichment of society
in the past two centuries so yes let's
discuss let's agree on removing
unfair government favors that enrich the
wealthy but abolishing
all billionaires by plunder that's a
really foolish proposition
fantastic well that was exactly on time
so well done
um now uh that was brilliant ryan so uh
and lindsay as well now we're gonna turn
to our audience questions
so just a reminder if you'd like to
submit yours then please
do the instructions to do so underneath
the video screen you can see a tab that
says
ask a question click on that and a text
box will drop down
type your question into the box and if
you want your name to be mentioned
type it in as well click send and be
patient
there are a lot of questions to get
through um i just want to kick
off before i get to those though because
i was quite interested
first of all with you lindsay that you
very subtly
changed or seemed to change the
proposition from abolish billionaires to
abolish billionaire
power and i wonder are would you be
happy with billionaires
on this planet if they had if they
didn't have the political power that
they have is that the key
distinction that you would make or is it
the wealth itself are they inseparable
the only way to remove their power is to
remove their wealth so i stand in favor
of both propositions to abolish
billionaires
to disallow the capacity for any
individuals to accrue such
excess of wealth and that is the sole
way
that we can abolish their power okay
and ryan i want to ask a question to you
because interestingly you made a
distinction between billionaires whose
fortune to build on rent extraction on
crony capitalism and the rest
and you uh argued that actually most
billionaires
don't get their wealth from rent
extraction
but you are aren't you implicitly sort
of
accepting that it is an empirical
question and if it could be
proved or demonstrated that it was the
other way around that actually
quite a lot of these guys maybe not all
but quite a lot
um do get it from those um crony
capitalism sources
um the you you would be on the other
side so isn't the question
um on isn't the proposition that you're
opposing here
don't um abolish or you're agreeing with
the proposition
abolish crony billionaires would you be
on would you be in favor of that if it
was presented in that way
well i think you want to treat the
underlying disease and not the symptoms
so i would never be in favor of anything
that was as broad brushes
abolish billionaires when uh the motion
that i would support would be something
along the lines of
abolish uh unfair government deck
tilting that leads
to the enrichment of certain individuals
and that's a very very different
proposition
i'd just like to make one point in
regard to to politics though
because we've heard a lot about
billionaire power in politics i think
there's two crucial points here
first of all there's no billionaire
world view you know george soros tom
steyer
other liberal billionaires are quite
often in hammer and tongs political
battles with charles coke and sheldon
adelson and other conservative and you
know libertarian
billionaires in politics i think it's
really wrong or misguided to
to talk about billionaires as if they
have
shared interests uh the second point
though is that to the extent that the
average views of the
of the super wealthy do differ from the
rest of the population
a study by larry bartles has tended to
find that on average
they tend to be much more worried about
budget deficits much more
open to immigration and more in favor of
shrinking
age-related spending programs well how's
that working out for them
uh we're moving in the opposite
direction to all on all of those things
and uh amazon and other major
tech owners are being dragged through
the courts in antitrust cases if they've
got so much political power
where is it okay now let's go to
audience question
there's one here for lindsay which is
about the practicalities of the
proposition you're you're endorsing and
the question is how do you
abolish billionaires do is it through a
maximum wage is it through
wealth taxes just talk us through how
you see this actually
uh being implemented sure i think two of
the best proposals are yes a wealth tax
and that does need to be implemented and
implemented at the global level and
certainly
the fact that we can agree different
global trade rules through organizations
like the world trade organization
means that it is feasible but first of
all you have to really challenge this
view that somehow
other countries have oligarchs i think
it was russian oligarchs that ryan
mentioned and carlos slim so it's
interesting to me that the rontier
exploitation
always stops right at the american
border where suddenly then you just sort
of zeep over the border
and any level of exploitation or
cronyism just sort of switches
and you cease to be an oligarch now
you're an
entrepreneur that great defining
aspect of supposed american
exceptionalism and that's simply a myth
it's completely untrue
places like the cato institute and
heritage foundation want us to believe
that and it's it's not true
ryan's point that rent seeking doesn't
exist in um
nations like the united kingdom and the
u.s is is
a false one and um there's increased
interest in what ben was speaking about
which is to try to measure this level of
rent seeking
because contrary to the 19th century
when economists like ricardo and smith
in the early 18th century before then
were interested in rent seeking
from land from all different types of
monopolistic holdings
we see studying this as extensively in
the 20th century so we don't even know
exactly how far
in what ways we can measure it more
effectively but economists do want it
measured more as has been suggesting and
that can then lead you to get at
the the type of policies the person who
asked this great question
is pointing to and i think maximum wages
and also
within companies uh ratios and
proportionality between what low
paid workers earn and ceos earn and
executive
individuals earn are one of the best
approaches to this so both wealth taxes
and uh
payment ratios yeah but lindsey let me
just
very briefly follow up on that because
we had an independent wealth commission
here in the uk which looked at this
question it's made up of people by no
means
hostile to wealth taxes and they
concluded it was just too practically
difficult to do
an annual recurring wealth tax because
of the nature of people's
assets isn't that a fundamental
challenge to the idea of a wealth tax if
we're
i think if we're capable of helping
bezos get to outer space we are capable
of overcoming the practicality of
taxation and this really gets back to
the adam smith point
that i quoted where he said a real
characteristic of feudalism
is the incapacity to make the most
powerful
people pay and so you were always
burdening the most weakened marginalized
people in society
and a mark of civility a mark of
civilization of the
is the capacity to have fair taxation
and to not let the richest people escape
taxes
just because they've got the money to do
so
okay ryan let's uh we've got a question
for you here and i'm going to combine it
with another question but
the question is how much of a
billionaire's wealth is a result of
their quotes brilliant
invention and how much is from the
exploitation
of their workers another question asked
how much is it due to public subsidy
you know we've talked well we've heard
about apple's uh innovations being uh
on the back of public investment and the
the question asks
even bezos thanks amazon workers for
paying for his
space travel didn't didn't that stick in
your crawl slightly because they were
doing no such thing they were buying
amazon services they weren't
using it to try and help him get into
space were they
no i don't think so they were buying
amazon services and um
jeff bezos's primary contribution to
social well-being has been providing
um lower-cost products um easily
available especially during a time of a
pandemic to millions and millions of
people around the world i think that's
where he generates his social uh
value um on the public investment point
yeah of course everybody
benefits to an extent of the provision
of real public goods we can
argue about what those public goods are
but the interesting thing is that over
the past 30 to 40 years
uh provision of genuine public goods by
government hasn't increased at all
almost all the
the growth of government has been in
fiscal transfers so that doesn't explain
if there's supposedly so much more rent
seeking now
why that rent-seeking has increased one
argument
might be that as as we become richer as
a society
as the demands on on governments grow
and as more resources are sucked in uh
to government and into washington dc in
particular
and we've got much less power at the the
state level over time
um actually it becomes a bit easier to
to rent seek and i just mentioned one
point in retort to something that
professor maguire said
which is that um in my remarks i did
actually mention
some of the favors that elon musk gets
from trying to get
states to play off each other in terms
of the explicit subsidies for tesla so
i'm not pretending that no rent seeking
exists in the us we have extensive farm
subsidies
that make some farmers
multi-millionaires incredibly rich
i would scrap those as well and the cato
institute spends a fair amount of time
arguing against these policies that
genuinely distort the playing field
all the while why these uh these
these uh left-wing individuals in the
democrat party who want wealth taxes
advocate for things like industrial
policies which which by definition
um are predicated on spraying subsidies
around their favored
industries right let me ask you about
the sort of the philanthropic
question which is attached to this
debate the the power that billionaires
have through the tax code because
then they use their their huge wealth to
go on their own
favored projects which might be good or
they might be bad
but is it does it not concern you as it
does many people that they're
effectively
being given this power to to promote
their own choices
and their own causes which may not fit
with what most of the
the population uh what does that is that
not a concern
well i probably abolished the charitable
deduction um altogether but let's think
about this logically let's suppose we
were introduced
to introduce a net wealth tax um
individual with a big block of wealth
then has three
potential things that he can do he can
reinvest that money into his business
and
into productive business assets to
create jobs create products that
that people might or might not want to
buy he can choose to blow that on
near-term consumption buy more property
or buy more yachts
or he can plow that money into
tax-exempt
things like charities and giving it to
his favored political causes
to institut you know organizations on
everything from
the nra through to trade unions that
actually do have quite extensive
political power so what would a
a wealth tax encourage actually it would
encourage more conspicuous consumption
and it would encourage more in the way
of uh political
and charitable giving which the
professor seems to oppose so i'm not
entirely sure how you square that with
the demands for a wealth tax
okay so lindsay we've got a question
here which i want to throw to you
because it's about political economy of
your proposal
and it says is a preference for
democratic control of capital which
you've advocated rather than private
billionaire control
contingent on having more effective
political
leaders and i suppose what it's
referring to is that people like richard
branson people like elon musk have a
kind of
um authority and credibility that often
political leaders don't
have um isn't that part of the thing
that you would have to address
to to be successful in abolishing
billionaires that actually they're
pretty popular
whether their popularity comes from
excessive media coverage is hard to say
and i i hate to
throw that back and say um the bbc or
where that sort of
showered endless hours of attention to
this sort of
interesting sort of space battle that's
being
um currently fought between the
billionaires is a question
because are they popular it seems to me
their popularity seems to be declining
the more that people see them on their
screens and realize that they spend so
much time in
you know wasting fossil fuels on um
egotistical battles to see who can be
the most
to spend the most hours in space so i
think
their popularity that's a that's in
dispute right now and i think it's
because people sense that inequality has
become
just so massive a problem that it needs
to be addressed
and in order to address it practically
we need to get political will to do so
and that gets back to your excellent
question ben
and mr boren's really i think important
points
about we need to have trust in
government to ensure that governments
won't be spending
money or subsidies partially in order to
have a more equitable society
but it's a chicken and egg scenario did
people start losing faith in government
and politicians
which are that some people were able to
essentially buy favors
or was the problem that governments
stopped really understanding the root
causes of inequality
and let different sectors be basically
unleashed from effective regulations and
i think it's a mixture of both
so the inequality that we've seen really
grow over the past 30 years
started in the 80s and it started with
massive deregulations of the
financial sector we need to look at
things like not letting speculative
actors really gouge and play with uh
nation's currencies in a ways that
really leads to destabilizing conditions
for people in the most marginalized
impoverished places in the world but it
can be done
it has been done we had fire taxes in
the mid-century
and this was incredibly effective at
compressing wealth levels
and it wasn't fully effective there were
still groups that were very much
left out from say franklin delano
roosevelt's fdr's effort to sort of make
sure that the new deal was equitably
distributed he still did not do enough
to say
um really support um uh black
sharecroppers for example who had
temporary jobs that were left out of
certain provisions of the nature of
those brought
but the key thing and part of the reason
was that it was pulled into
sort of dixie southerner wealthy
interests so
even some of the most proactive
progressive politicians
are sometimes too beholden to wealthy
people
but that we can't stop that by just
trying to fix a problem in government we
have to fix the fact that some people
have
much wealth and can engage in excessive
lobbying activities which is a type
of rent seeking so you can't reduce rent
seeking unless you attack the problem of
lobbying
by the wealthy and it's not a market fix
it's a government fix that
i come needs to that sure go ahead ryan
um
well i spent a fair bit of time with
politicians when i was in the uk and
believe me you don't need to be a
billionaire
uh to get their attention they're
incredibly cheap dates
um and um i i just i can't think of any
instance
through history where somebody through
losing their wealth over time by making
bad investment decisions or whatever
um has had such a fall from grace
in terms of being able to access
politicians that we've seen a
fundamental
um change in economic policy um and
i think even if you were to have the
sorts of wealth tax
that the professor has advocated um
a lot of these people who are currently
billionaires would still be
extremely rich and and as i say you
don't have to have that many millions
to have the attention of politicians and
i don't really see
what the marginal impact of going from
999 million 999
999 to a billion has
in terms of an individual's political
impact
okay we've got a question uh sort of
following on from that for you ryan it's
from mark and devon
and he wants to know how billionaires
tell us how billionaires do influence
democracy
and distort elections with lobbying and
controlling
media he wants you to spell it out at
the process
well i'm not the one making that
proposition so it's incredibly hard for
me to do so but let me give you
an example of how they're unable to
control democracy in the way that they
would like and that is
mayor bloomberg's presidential campaign
he had
uh you know endless funds to plow into
it and was quite prepared to do so but
he crashed and burned and there's a
simple kind of explanation for that
which is that voters didn't want to vote
for him and no matter how many ads he
bought
he found that incredibly difficult of
course we don't like to admit it but
hillary clinton spent
vastly more on her presidential campaign
than donald trump
as well so whatever you think about
donald trump as an individual
this idea that there's a sure-fire link
between money and politics
um i'm afraid it is just not that they
know it would be churlish to suggest
that
um people with money didn't have on the
margin more influence than the
the average uh voter but i would
politely suggest that actually
economic interest groups that can club
together that can provide
both votes and money to politicians
are much more powerful within the
political system
than some of these individual
billionaires as i say as you can see
from the fact that amazon's
um founder jeff bezos mark
zuckerberg and facebook and bill gates
through the 90s
are currently being dragged through the
courts as joe biden has appointed a
whole bunch of antitrust
lawyers and antitrust intellectuals
who want to completely cut those
businesses down to size
if these guys had full control over the
political system as has been alluded to
um how do you how does one explain these
current trends in politics that we're
seeing
okay lindsay we've got a question for
you and it says
do you not think that bill gates shows
that billionaires can do a lot of
good with their wealth obviously this is
coming in the context of the pandemic
he had invested quite a lot of his own
money in um
in vaccines beforehand isn't
isn't that an example of where
billionaire wealth can combine with
public
uh authorities and public money to do
quite a lot of good in the world
i think uh people can be well motivated
and mr gates has spent um some of the
funds at his foundation
towards vaccine development but the
accessibility of those vaccines
in global poor reasons regents is very
very poor right now and that's partly
because
he unlike people like biden unlike
people like
the head of the who has never supported
a waiver on patent protections
that would enable uh vaccines to be
distributed
more widely his foundation finally did
concede that a waiver might be good
although he has personally not himself
placed his support behind it
only after an eventual concession by the
head of the us government
so this brings me back to sort of ryan's
point because i'm a little bit surprised
by his argument if i understand it
correctly
he is saying that he doesn't support
crony capitalism he supports competitive
capitalism but he's been criticizing the
efforts to
sort of apply antitrust laws to some of
the monopoly
positions of places like microsoft or
amazon so it does seem to me that
sometimes places like the cato institute
say that they want more competition
but then they oppose any legal efforts
to make it actually happen so they only
like it when the law
is usually is used to enforce the
ability of people like jeff bezos to
plunder his
own workers well they're never really in
favor of this word plunger when it comes
to
the redistribution that needs to happen
in order to have a fairer
society ryan
um in the similar territory we've got a
question that
asks you what evidence do you have that
innovation would
stop if there was an earnings cap
affecting uh billionaires and rich
people
and i want to link this to something
you're saying in your opening remarks
about
the motivator effect of earning you know
having billions of pounds of wealth
it's pretty hard to prove isn't it that
um
that is the key factor which is making
entrepreneurs that we all want to to
come up with these innovations and drive
wealth creation uh is the key factor
as lindsay was saying in her remarks we
did have a regime earlier in the century
which was
much more a tax regime which uh which
attacks wealth much more highly and we
still had innovations
in that area so what how can you say
definitively that that a billionaire
attacks would have this
your wealth tax would have this damaging
effect well i can't say definitively but
you either believe
financial incentives matter or you don't
i'm afraid and i
i do think it's misguided to compare the
period immediately after
world war ii with today and we're in a
much more kind of globalized economy now
what does that mean well uh earlier on
somebody asked the question
about whether ceos these founders are
more talented
than before more deserving i would try
and echo friedrich hayek here and say
markets don't allocate um resources
according to
desert or pure merit uh if they did
and you know if given the results we
have they
they clearly don't do that a lot um for
some of the reasons that we've talked
about
um why are ceos paid much more than
average employees now than they were 30
to 40 years ago
because even though their relative
talent might not have gone up
substantially the stakes in a globalized
economy
are that much higher uh companies are
competing in
in much larger global markets so
decisions that ceos do make
are more consequential than they are
before
and there's been good academic evidence
uh to bear this out if you look at the
impact of ceo resignations
deaths when those happen in
the day afterwards the 30-day period
afterwards
they tend to have big impacts on the
company's stock price particularly if
they're unexpected
of course um and that shock
impact has actually grown over the past
30 to 40
years now somebody might come back to me
and say well hang on
but also employees are ordinary
employees are part of this global
marketplace too so why hasn't their pay
gone up in the same way well the answer
there i think is that
uh ceos ceos their their impact on a
company
tends to be uh multiplicative
uh whereas um the impact of an employee
is additional now what do i mean by that
the ceo has the power to
completely try and change corporate
culture in some ways to
advocate for trying out a completely new
product line in a way that an individual
employee doesn't and if ceos get those
decisions wrong
as the movements in stock prices show us
when ceos move
it can lead to billions and billions and
billions
of dollars or pounds being lost or
gained to a company's value
so you know i'm not pretending that all
ceos uh
ceo pay founder pay is purely
meritocratic it's also a feature of
the supply and demand features of a
modern dynamic economy too
so ryan we've had a question from
someone who says they were
from germany and born in the early 70s
and they are open on this question so
this is the
audience member that you vote
so he says he's sitting in the middle of
the headline question but the point he
says most of today's billionaires
have either inherited their wealth or
benefited from a post-war period
with far higher levels of social
equality
now i i think you dispute the idea that
most have inherited their wealth but
it's interesting that you have made a
couple of concessions it seems to me
you've you've talked about you would get
rid of the charitable deduction
and that you are uh you would be in
favor of going after rent extracting
billionaires but what about inheritance
because this goes back to your
point about motivations if someone
inherits
billions and there are people on the
rich list who do inherit
would you be in favor of disinheriting
them because that surely can't motivate
them
um to do any you know once they've got
it they can't be motivated to get it
that's true but the ability to pass on a
fortune to your children can be a
motivator
but i just think this is a overblown
issue to be honest if you look at the
forbes 400 list the 400 richest
americans the proportion that herself
made has actually gone up
from 40 in 1982 to 69
today the sunday times rich list 94 of
britain's uh richest thousand people
were self-made including you know
entrepreneurs like richard branson
uh james dyson um
by my count and um you know i went
through this
yesterday if you look at the annual list
of the forbes 400
there's just 21 people who were on it in
1982 who was still on it
um in in the most recent uh
list and um if you look at those 400
people again
somebody who did some work on this a few
years ago found just 69 of them
uh 30 years later um were
people that inherited money from
people on that original list so i just
think that this kind of whole
piketty argument that there's this huge
dynastic
wealth accumulation problem is a bit of
a myth
um and the second reason i think that
aside from looking at the pure numbers
is if you actually look at the growth in
wealth or the changing wealth between
those
on the list who actually inherited it
and those who didn't
uh the self-made ones appear to see much
much higher returns
on their investments than uh the people
who inherited it so i think over time
that problem kind of works itself out in
a as so long as
so long as and this is where i do
concede so long as we have an open
dynamic competitive economy now lindsay
we've had a couple
more practical challenges to your
position one of the audience members is
asking
um how have measures to implement wealth
taxes by other countries fared in the
past because france had a wealth tax
and had to retract it and that's well
argued a lot of people use for saying
it's simply not practical to tax wealth
in the way that you would advocate
in the modern global economy um and
there's another question which talks
about
um if we're not if um is loopholes
wouldn't these very innovative
billionaires effectively just find ways
to shift their money and evade the tax
net
we don't have a global government that's
just a reality we're probably
well we're almost certainly not going to
get one how do you
get around those practical issues yeah
very good
important uh questions and it really
points back i think to
mr bourne's point about the fact that
now we live in this
supposedly unprecedentedly dynamic
globalized world where you've got more
interaction between nations in a way he
is implying
you didn't have in the past you're
crackling up at the moment
yeah do you want to try again i'm afraid
yeah
maybe if you unplug your uh headphones
and put them in again
it'll
it'll
okay and while we wait for lindsay's
headphones to uh hopefully get better
maybe we can go to ryan if yours is
still working
question is why do you think there are
so few women billionaires
are they not just as innovative as men
um i don't think there's any reason why
there shouldn't be more women
billionaires i think
partly at the moment it's a reflection
of historic
um educational inequalities that one
hopes will work themselves out over time
um there is a big open question i think
as to the extent to which preferences or
social expectations
about raising families has has shaped uh
a willingness or ability um to
work the extortionate hours that many
founders of companies and top
entrepreneurs um
who tend to see their business as a
vocation
um how many hours they work
i haven't looked at that question in in
detail so
i don't have a better answer than that
i'm afraid
um but i think there's huge female
talent
out there um and i see no reason over
the next generation why we won't see a
huge growth in
the number of uh female billionaires
around the world
brilliant um are you able to hear me
great sorry about that it was my
connection lindsay do you want to
continue making that point you were
making earlier before i cut you off
sure thanks ben no no problem and thank
you very much and this is
you know the audience questions are so
dynamic and important and i just want to
get back to this point of globalization
because ryan has suggested that we live
in a sort of unprecedented
globalized world i think that's a myth
when you have
the for example the transatlantic slave
trade there was global interconnections
there was a need to try for some nations
to take a moral lead
in abolishing the type of gross
exploitation
and brutality that underpin that system
and today
we do have a globalized world but we do
also have precedence for ways that
through global contacts and different
organizations
that are responsive to member states
that aren't a global government
but that have restrictions on the
ability of different powerful
governments to exploit other nations
those um those those governance
arrangements
do exist in places like the united
nations and the world trade organization
and we could hear and try to place
citizen pressure on governments
to reach the type of global agreement
that is needed to ensure that these huge
winding wealth gaps
cease to place such a burden on people's
children on your neighbors on the future
we don't want to live in a world where
wealth is hoarded in
so few hands while so much poverty
increases both in wealthy nations and
inequality is growing in
almost every single nation today
including some of the emerging economies
incl emerging powerhouses like china in
india
and this is leading to a world where we
are really regressing
the type of feudal anti-democratic
types of governance systems that we
fought so hard
to out to abolish and to overcome and
what we what is needed is market
democracy to apply the same constraints
that were once put
on monarchs and feudals to the market to
ensure
that the wealth that is made in such
concentrated ways
in that global system begins to be
better distributed
and is not just held in so many few
hands and
so many few companies that have very
monopolistic
uh structures and patterns underpinning
them there was a great article today
this in the past month in the guardian
on just how monopolistic
the food system is in the united states
for example
so when ryan says he's in favor of a
competitive economy it just doesn't
square with the facts of just how
monopolistic our industries have
become right ryan's shaking his head
there but we have come to that moment
you're going to get you've planned to
respond brian because it's summing up
time
so two minutes from you responding to
that and also giving your final argument
well thank you ladies and gentlemen
thank you to intelligence squared that
was
extremely fun uh so far but i hope when
deciding your vote tonight you've seen
enough to recognize the real
pig in a poke you're being asked to
support
because not only did my opponent fail to
explain
how billionaires would be abolished
without significant damage to the
economy i suspect because that's an
impossible task
but i think she really failed to explain
what the lasting effects would be
of living in a society in which people
were effectively banned from getting
super rich even if they created
fantastic innovative products that we
decide we want and need because we value
them
highly i'd suggest politely you've been
presented with two very different
pictures and visions of the world
tonight one
mine which you know you might not be
surprised to think i think represents
reality
which acknowledges the power of economic
growth and the fact that
over the past two centuries things have
been getting much better
and which acknowledges that poverty is
not what needs to be explained when you
look at human history
its wealth and which has a theory and
evidence to show
i believe that billionaire wealth comes
primarily from creating value for us
on the other hand you've got the
professor's vision
which i think is a doom and gloom
prospectus um
which is hostile to billionaire
innovation
no matter what the source of that wealth
is
and is predicated i'm afraid on wealth
being somewhat of a zero-sum game
an outcome which i think doesn't bear
witness to the facts of the world we
live in
but is probably something that would
result if the policies that
the professor proposes were implemented
now we hear a lot these days about
populism of the dangers of telling
the people that their misfortunes or
hardships are the result of some
malevolent other some enemy within
that if only these people went away or
exterminated or plundered all would be
well
well i'd just again politely suggest
that this motion
is populism on speed as you vote
remember that an affirmative for this
motion would not be
voting to abolish the activities that
made people rich unfairly
the motion is voting to abolish
billionaires
entirely i urge you tonight to reject
this motion
not because every billionaire is a
pillar of morality
but because of the immorality and
absurdity of such a crude proposal
to abolish all of them excellent thank
you so much ryan now over to you lindsey
for your two minute closing argument
thank you so well i think you can learn
a lot from people across the ideological
spectrum we can learn things from
thinkers like hayek he's someone i read
a lot for example we can learn things
from socialist
thinkers i want to end with uh first
with a brief quote
by a liberal thinker isaiah berlin
who once said total freedom
for the wolves means death
for the sheep and what he meant by that
is that unless you constrain some of the
predators in society who exploit
and live off the exploitation of the
livelihoods of others
then you have essentially brutality
and a bloodbath and the type of
preventable deaths that we're seeing
at the scale of something like the covid
pandemic today where if only
we actually restricted the ability of
some corporations to exclusively produce
vaccines for example
enriching their ceo billionaire owners
in many instances
we would have more access to life-saving
vaccines
so i think it's interesting for example
that my opponent mr bourne suggested
that there's something hostile
in the motion to abolish billionaires
and i
i can see how that might be the
perception it's a strong
stance it's an aggressive dance and it
almost has a
a a level of abruptness or hostility to
it he used the word
hostility specifically i think but that
hostility and violence is already
happening
it is happening in the violent
dispossession of workers
and their livelihoods by mr bezos
and his pals it's happening in the
violence of being fired for a job
for trying to organize a union to fight
against poverty wages
it's happening in the violent the earth
that is ensuing through these wasteful
and egotistical
space jaunts this is not wealth creation
let's face it the space wars that we've
been seeing right now
it's a pissing content it's a pissing
contest between the world's richest and
to be very blunt about it yes i am a
professor but i like to speak uh
bluntly about issues when it's called
for guess who's getting pissed upon
it's the little guy the truth underlying
the frame
abolish billionaires is a proud defense
of that little guy's interests defend
him
from what my opponent wants which is
your continued
civility to the mega rich he wants you
and the people that you elect to have no
power to tax or to constrain them
he wants rule by the wealthy
whereas i think many people want an end
to that rule
and to get there we must abolish
billionaires
and their power thank you
well thank you uh thank you both for
those summaries of your cases now it's
time for you
the audience to decide so please
vote now for or against the motion
abolish billionaires via the poll which
will be appearing
on your screen and if you're still not
sure then by all means
still vote i'm decided um just a
reminder at the start of the event
in the pre-poll the audience voted 56
uh in favor of the motion uh and 11
against the motion to abolish
billionaires and 11
were undecided um
so we while we wait for the results
to come up i just want to thank both of
our speakers i think it's really
these debates can sometimes shed more
heat than light but i'd like to say
personally speaking i got a lot more
light than
uh than i expected uh and then
yes from these debates so thank you so
much
for that um we're just waiting for the
results to pop up on the channel
now um um
are you both are you as one first
question you're both in america
um lindsay and ryan are you both based
in america
not my i'm both in london i work at
university of essex
and i commute there from east london
right and but ryan you're you're brit
but you're in dc is that right
yeah i'm based in washington dc so i've
been holed up here for most of the
pandemic and find it very difficult to
get back even to visit yeah
i just wonder to what extent one's view
on this will be colored to some extent
by where
where one's based because levels of
inequality are different in different
countries uh but anyway that's another
question we i can announce the final
results and they are
for the motion to abolish billionaires
57
against 34
undecided nine percent
so four wins uh 57
um and uh ryan ryan's motion
did gain some percentage points but not
enough to overturn the result
so a very interesting result there
that's that's
brilliant so well all that remains to
say is thanks again to lindsey and ryan
uh for taking part uh an excellent
debate
thanks to you the audience
you